hello and welcome you're logged into the
fourth of 12 berry soil and nutrient
management webinars sponsored by the
northeast sustainable research and
extension program better known as
northeast sayre and hosted by cornell
university department of horticulture
and cornell cooperative extension
my name is kathy heidenreich and i'll be
your host for this webinar
i just want to take care of a few
housekeeping things before we begin
see the note
in the notes box about webinar number
six it was originally scheduled for 9 12
and because of a schedule conflict had
to be moved to
not 9 12 i'm sorry 12 9 had to be moved
to 12 16 and we apologize for any
inconvenience in the dates
i also want to point out to you that
there's a new file that you can download
in the files box the sphere fact sheet
this is a list of agronomy fact sheets
that the cornell nutrient management
program has put together
and they have implications across a
wider range of crops and so marvin pritz
our speaker from last week has selected
several of those titles
and he thinks that they will help
provide some background information for
you so feel free to download that list
of fact sheets and the urls to get to
them
one of the other housekeeping things
that i'd like to take care of is during
our first webinar we
inadvertently omitted a
pre-test question number 14
so what i'm going to do is open that now
and if you'll just select the answer
that
best fits your knowledge
we'll get that out of the way
okay the poll is open please register
your response
i'll move it over here where you can see
it a little better there
we'll meet a couple more seconds people
are still signing in to give them a
chance to participate in the poll
okay i will open it again at the end
so that those who joined us later can
have a chance to participate
i just want to remind you during the
presentation if you have comments or
questions feel free to put them into the
chat box
and eric hanson our speaker will be
watching that while he's speaking and
we'll address them
you can also participate by using the
uh
little signals at the top you see the
the man with his hand raised on the top
menu bar
there's lots of options for you to
make some sort of a comment there feel
free to use those as we go along
as always there are links in the box on
the bottom left
the first is for northeast ser the
second is for the webinar archives each
webinar is recorded and posted on monday
of the following week so that you can
review it or if you missed it so that
you'll be able to hear it
all right then we're ready to shift to
the presentation
our speaker today is dr eric hanson from
michigan state university he grew up in
connecticut and earned his bachelor's
degree from nasa in college
his ms
from the university of maine studying
low bush blueberries and his phd at
oregon state university working in
orchard nutrition
he's now professor and extension
specialist in the department of
horticulture at msu his primary
responsibility is to provide production
information to bury crop producers
he also
does research on a variety of production
topics including fertilization weed
management high tunnel berry production
growth regulator use and organic
production challenges for blueberries
and raspberries
his teaching includes classes on plant
mineral nutrition and very crop
production
welcome eric
yeah thank you kathy and hi everyone i
am excited about this because we have
quite a bit of time to cover a topic in
a fair amount of detail so thanks kathy
and and marvin for putting on this uh
organizing this webinar uh series
so today we'll be talking about uh
means of correcting uh soil nutritional
problems for berries and today we'll
just
emphasize pre-plant considerations and
things you should be
concerned about
prior to planting
there
are a number of things beyond nutrition
that of course you'd be concerned about
uh prior to planting
uh any berry crop and um so if you look
at a a bear site there are things that
you ought to be uh thinking about that
may relate to nutrition or they they may
not relate to
to nutrition
some things that come to my mind
are first to have a good appreciation of
how texture varies across the site so
your site may contain one or more
soil types
you should have an idea
where those breaks in soil type occur
because that may influence how you
manage nutrition in coming years
you might consider the history of
management on the site was it had it
been used for
farming for a long time
do you think it would
benefit from some cover cropping or
manure or compost additions
that would
build up organic matter in the soil
are there wet spots
this does relate to nutrition to some
degree because it interacts with
fertility but if there are poorly
drained areas you might consider also
where
tile draining
drainage and
indoor surface
ditching may help to get rid of
excessive water
and then lastly of course have you done
the
adequate job of soil testing for ph and
nutrient levels prior to
prior to establishing your your plant
and i think that topic was covered in
the previous uh
webinar
so a lot of things to consider other
than uh nutrition
i think uh previously uh
webinars uh covered topics of uh
soil analyses and wanted to
reiterate i guess that there are a
number of private and university labs
that you could choose from to do soil
analyses and my
my opinion is you should pick one and
stick with it
that the uh
and then just use the interpretation
recommendations from that lab
because uh of course uh different labs
use different uh analytical
and extraction methods for for nutrients
and ph and lime requirements so make
make it simpler on yourself and
stick with one one lab
so the first consideration is uh prior
to
planting is of course ph and
we have two basic groups of berry crops
here and brambles and strawberries tend
to like
a slightly acidic
soil
blueberries and cranberries are very
acid loving so they
are way down on the
ph scale so the first
order of business is getting the ph in
the range where you would
like it for these uh these plants
so if the ph is too
too low uh liming is uh in order
and this is uh lime is essentially
calcium carbonate and that
dissolves slowly in
soil solutions and it releases calcium
and carbonate anions and
that's how
ph is reduced by limiting materials but
there are a lot of different uh liming
materials and a number of different
considerations for choosing the the best
type
the reasons for liming are
first to reduce a possibility of
toxic levels of aluminum or manganese so
as ph increases the solubility of those
two elements declines
so you
reduce the
availability of those to the plants and
the potential for toxicity
it
lyming supplies calcium and depending on
the source of magnesium
it increases the availability of
phosphorus if you're outside of the
range
required by the crops
and it has some kind of interesting
effects on microbial activity and some
of those are nitrogen
fixation so legumes tend to do better at
a higher ph range in terms of their
efficiency
nitrogen fixation
nitrification is the
um uh
oxidation of uh ammonium to produce
nitrate
uh the
microbes that are responsible for that
also we
prefer a higher ph so limiting tends to
speed up that process and of course
organic matter decomposition and and
nitrogen mineralization from organic
matter
uh tend to be
promoted by more neutral ph ranges
so how do you choose a lime
source well a number of different
considerations here first the
neutralizing value
so how
effective it is in
increasing ph of the reaction rate and
this is essentially
dictated by the size of lime particles
the need for magnesium
and then of course the cost of the
material
how easy it is to
apply and then the availability in your
your location
so let's start with um
the neutralizing value of lime materials
and these are all measured relative to
that of
pure calcium carbonate so that's how
how they're all compared
so that's given a neutralizing value of
a hundred the
dolomitic
lime
can be a little lower or a little higher
than pure calcium carbonate
calcitic lime or high cow lime
tends to be
a little bit
lower than pure calcium carbonate
because it has some impurities
um hydrated lime is much higher in
activity
marl
excuse me a minute i need to cough here
sorry about that
getting over a cold
um marl is
kind of a
lime uh mud uh and it's mined in
different locations and that
varies a whole lot in liming
neutralizing value so that can be
pretty close to limestone
or much much lower
and then i i listed gypsum
at the bottom just to indicate that
that is not a
liming material so people think about
calcium as being a liming material
and it's not the calcium it's the
carbonate so calcium sulfate or
gypsum
has no effect on on ph
and then the other consideration then is
the
speed of reaction and this is pretty
much dictated by the
particle size uh and how that influences
the surface
area of lime
materials
so
this chart indicates a
breakdown of the
particles by size so the
smaller mesh size
are the larger particles so mesh size is
holes per
per
inch and then the
vertical
axis is the percentage of the material
reacting in three years
so you can see a
material that's uh larger than this size
of 20 for the most part reacts fairly
well within a year or two of
application to soils
stuff between mesh size 8 and 20
reacts very slowly so
less than half of it's uh reacted within
three years
and then material that's very big zero
to eight mesh size is almost inert in
soil so
when you think about the value of a lime
material if it contains a lot of uh
eight to twenty uh mesh size uh
particles uh that stuff's pretty uh
pretty much worthless from
a quick acting uh standpoint in soils
so the
smaller the mess size the
or the smaller the particles the quicker
these things are going to react in the
soil
another type of
lime that's used in
fruit production in various areas
is pelletized or sometimes called pell
lime
and this material is actually a very
fine
mesh material
up to 100 mesh
of and it can be either
calcitic a high cal lime or a dilemmatic
lime
and it's uh
formulated into small
pellets using binders so the pellets are
fairly big but it's important to realize
that the
the actual limestone in it is very fine
so pell lime generally
reacts about as quickly and neutralizes
the very same amount of acidity as
egg lime with the same neutralizing
value and there's some question about
you can imagine that you're putting this
a large pellet
of
almost powdered uh limestone in in the
soil
and it does create kind of a
a high ph zone
around that immediate area of the pellet
and the
as a result the remainder of the pellet
may um
that may inhibit the
solubility of the remainder of the
pellet so there's some question about
whether the fact that it comes in a
pellet or not uh affects how quickly it
reacts
and i don't have a good answer
for you on that but generally i would
think a
pel lime is acting about the same as
as far as the neutralizing value of a
regular egg lime
the reason to consider this is it is uh
because it's pelletized you can spread
it through
any fertilizer spreader and it's easy to
handle
you know that a lot of
lime materials uh are dusty
and you can actually lose some during
application to to the wind and that
wouldn't be the case with a pelleted
material
of course you you need to pay for all
that convenience so these uh pelleted
materials are much more expensive
than regular egg lime
couldn't get this to
speed along here
now it speeds along too quickly so
occasionally we're interested in
lowering soil ph
for raspberries and strawberries this is
uncommon but it's certainly a
common desire in uh for blueberry sites
and the uh the reason for that is that
ph can be
higher than a desired uh range for uh
blueberries
and under michigan conditions if we we
get a ph above 5.5 or so
we start seeing this iron chlorosis that
you see in the in the pictures here so
we want to avoid that by
planting blueberries in a soil with a
proper ph
and there are a number of
materials that will reduce soil uh ph
but sulfur is the best one to use
sulfur is elemental sulfur
and
depending on the brand if this can come
as prills
it can come as chips or even powdered
and these materials range from 90 to 95
sulfur so if uh recommendation is
for uh 500 pounds per acre you'd want to
increase that by 5 to 10 percent
on account of the
lower
than 100 percent content of sulfur
the prills are uh of course easiest to
use they're they're low in dust
they're easy to spread with a
fertilizer spreader
chipped
sulfur is kind of intermediate it tends
to come with a lot of different chip
sizes and it's also with quite a bit of
dust in uh in the material and of course
powdered is difficult to
to use all together although i sometimes
recommend powdered sulfur to acidify the
soil around a couple of blueberry bushes
in somebody's background backyard
because they can buy a small quantity of
it
iron
sulfate is a salt
this also reduces soil ph
it reacts quickly in soils but it's very
expensive because it's about 1 6 as
potent
as sulfur
for reducing soil ph so you have to use
a lot of it
and as a result there may be a potential
for salt stress if you're using a lot of
this material immediately before
applying or before planting blueberries
the
aluminum sulfate
is pretty much the same as iron sulfate
it acts quite quickly
and but requires high rates and because
it contains aluminum there's a potential
for
accumulating toxic levels of aluminum so
that's not generally recommended either
so sulfur is the best
choice
sometimes people
think about using
acidifying nitrogen fertilizers
to reduce soil ph and i wanted to talk
about that a little bit so
ammonium sulfate is a very acidic
nitrogen fertilizer
it helps to maintain soil ph low but it
shouldn't be used
to
reduce soil ph initially and the reason
is that it if you're applying enough of
that to reduce ph you'll
apply a huge amount of nitrogen that's
not needed and maybe
damaging so
for example one pound of sulfur
provides about the same acidity
as two and a 2.8 pounds of ammonium
sulfate
so if you had a recommendation for 500
pounds of sulfur
this would be equivalent to an
application of
1400 pounds of
ammonium sulfate
and that would deliver almost 300 pounds
of nitrogen so
it's not something you'd want to put on
prior to planting a
blueberries for example
it certainly wouldn't be efficient and
probably wouldn't be very cost effective
either
there was a question from jeff about how
important is sulfur to this group of
plants and
generally i i haven't
seen or heard of any
instances where sulfur
is actually deficient in these
this group of plants
so sulfur of course is a essential
element but most soils contain adequate
levels for
uh for these crops so it's not to say
that it can't happen but it's i'd say
it's un
uncommon
and then a comment from uh charlie uh
it's very important for blueberries and
cranberries and
you know that that is true uh but again
if ph
is
acidic enough for those
those crops
then there's
automatically abundant levels of
sulfate in the soil
um i don't think of um
any instances where you have to apply
sulfur uh strictly as a fertilizer i
think most of those uh soils contain
adequate uh
sulfur levels
and
jeff has another question with less
sulfur and
rain water could we start seeing
sulfur deficiency on on coarse soils you
know i think certainly possible but um
no instances of that that i'm aware of
i think it's related to that is uh you
know the
switch away from sulfur as a
fungicide so there are a number of those
materials that have been applied
routinely for different uh reasons and
perhaps
the needs will change over over time
uh in a little bit about
sulfur
so
this material
is oxidized by a specific group of
bacteria in the soil so
it is a biological process
and it works very well when the soils
are moist
and warm and well aerated
so the bacteria oxidize that sulfur to
produce sulfuric acid
uh but it's a
biological process so it keep in mind
that
nothing much happens during the off
season when the soils are too cold for
those bacteria to work
and we normally think a sulfur is
requiring the better part of a whole
growing season to
fully react in the soil
it may take a little longer than that or
it may take a little less than that
depending on how much is applied and
perhaps a microbial community in in the
soil
the
important thing is to try to incorporate
it for a good um
distribution in the root zone for for a
quick
reaction
so if you were
establishing a site for
blueberries for example and you
needed to apply sulfur to reduce ph
you have a choice of broadcasting that
material or perhaps banding it
along the rows where the blueberry
bushes will go
and in most cases i think it's best to
broadcast over the whole site
i know in some cases where particularly
on a heavier soil that's
uh highly buffered that it may be best
to
or most economical to bandit where the
bushes will go because you only need to
apply
perhaps half as much as you would
broadcast it
and kathy i can't seem to advance things
real well i don't know if it's my
computer
um
sulfur requirements so
this is the amount of sulfur required to
reduce ph to
a level of uh four um starting with uh
initial ph of five or five five six or
six five
and the important point i wanted to make
here is is how
instrumental the soil type is to the
amount of sulfur that's required to drop
ph so you can see that um
from for a given drop in ph it will we
take two or three times as much
uh to drop ph on a loam soil opposed to
a sand
and then four or five times as much to
drop it on a clay opposed to a sand
so that's why people say that it it may
not be economical to produce blueberries
on a
a soil with a very high initial ph
if that soil is also highly buffered a
heavier soil
so you take a a great deal of sulfur
generally as a caution we'd say if
you're applying more than 500 pounds of
sulfur you'd probably should consider
splitting that application into
into two
i wanted to mention also that
sulfur can produce
hydrogen sulfide in soils that are
poorly drained so if if there are
water logged areas in the field
hydrogen sulfide can be produced and
that's toxic to
to plant roots so that can cause damage
so
in a
situation like this you can imagine that
if a grower put his sulfur down
prior to planting these young
blueberries
and he has these
flooded or poorly drained areas
that you could have
toxic levels of hydrogen sulfide develop
in in those areas but it's primarily
because of the
anaerobic conditions in the in the root
zone
let's see
pre-plant phosphorus use so the
recommendation here would be to
incorporate prior to planting at rates
indicated by soil test results
so you can choose materials based on the
cost per unit of
p205
and the availability of phosphorus from
those materials so the the standard
materials
super phosphate and concentrated super
phosphate are
nearly all available meaning they're all
almost 100 percent soluble
so the choice between those of course
would be
based on the cost per unit of p205
i want i mentioned rock phosphate here
because this is the mineral that
these other phosphate
fertilizers are manufactured from
and it's fairly high in phosphorus but
very low and soluble phosphorus
i think it may have some utility in
organic settings but also
um
in uh in blueberry settings where you
want a slow release of phosphorus over
time so
in high ph soils rock phosphate would be
non-effective because the solubility
goes down with as ph goes up but in
acidic soils this might be a nice
material to supply a gradual
release of phosphorus over time as long
as the ph is low
uh jeff is asking uh split uh sulfur
applications um that you plow down half
and disc in half
that would be uh fine
typically i think more about
perhaps uh applying uh half in one
season and then half in the spring prior
to uh
planting
so that you have
part of that reacting in the soil at
different time intervals
and uh
problems with applying monoammonium or
diamonium phosphate and
so pre-plant those materials don't make
much sense
as phosphorus sources because you really
don't want to be
putting a whole lot of nitrogen in to
the ground
prior to planting
typically
and i would uh
say that
they're very very expensive sources of
phosphorus so if if you need uh the
nitrogen uh in those materials then it
it
is an economic source of the two
nutrients but all you're looking for is
phosphorus then it's an expensive source
of phosphorus
eric are you still having problems
advancing
yeah hasn't happened before so i was
wondering if it
had something to do with the
website
i can advance from here if you just tell
me when
oh okay thank you and then uh pre-plant
uh uh potassium so
again you'd be incorporating this prior
to planting at rates based on the soil
test results
so the materials of choice would be
dependent on the cost again per unit of
nutrients so per unit of k2o
the need for other nutrients and the
potential
hazard
from
chloride
so
the
typical materials are potassium chloride
or murietta potash and potassium
sulfate
and
these
fairly high in
a k2o
percentage
potassium chloride is the least
expensive of these uh based uh uh
per unit of uh k2o bases
potassium sulfate's a little bit more
expensive and
potassium magnesium sulfate
would be a quite high
cost source of
potassium
so the other
consideration then is what other
nutrients would you need so if soil
tests indicate that magnesium is low
then this
potassium magnesium sulfate or sopo mag
may be a good
good choice economically
and then the potential hazard of
from chlorine i wanted to mention a
little bit so
you know you usually have a choice
between
sop or the
sulfate and
the muriat or the potassium chloride and
the muriat is nearly always quite a bit
cheaper
of course it contains chloride so there
is a potential for causing uh damage to
plants because of that so my
my feeling on uh use of
this is that if you're using uh
relatively low levels
100
100
pound rates
maybe up to 200 pound rates of
potassium
that
chloride is is probably safe on most of
these crops
i think if you
are on a sandy
soil and are concerned about this that
and you still want to go with a cheaper
chloride source that
application in the fall would be a great
idea so if you apply
chloride in the fall most of that
anion is going to leach out of the root
zone by the
end of the winter so that reduces the
potential risk
so again if if you're using a
lower rates of
potash i think in most cases the
myriad is
is safe and if you have some concern
about the safety
then you might consider applying that in
the fall so that you give time for the
chloride to leach out of the uh out of
the root zone
did you advance that kathy thank you
uh pre-plant magnesium and calcium so um
again incorporate prior to planting uh
based on soil test results and here the
the choice of materials would be based
on the
cost per unit of nutrient again
the need for a ph adjustment and then
the need for other nutrients
so the cheapest source of calcium and
magnesium would be the limestones
calcitic lime is normally greater than
30 percent
calcium
and quite low in magnesium
dolomitic lime is uh lower in
calcium and higher in magnesium but the
actual ratios vary depending on
on the source
so those would be the good
choices if you're trying to increase ph
if you need magnesium but you don't want
to increase ph
then magnesium sulfate
would be a good
choice
if you needed
calcium but you did not want to
increase
a ph and calcium sulfate would be a good
choice
and of course potassium magnesium
sulfate supplement is uh
provides both of those
nutrients
i wanted to talk a little bit about uh
interesting case of gypsum and this this
came out of work that marvin pritz uh um
did a number of years ago in in uh
new york
and the whole story
my thinking is not in on this but it's
an interesting situation in that uh
gypsum um
it supplies calcium but doesn't
alter ph is is known to be uh real
beneficial in soils that are
uh either saline uh that me meaning high
in salts or sodic meaning high in in
sodium
so
in those cases
gypsum tends to improve the
adhesion of clay my seals to one another
to flaculation and that improves water
infiltration and drainage in those
soils
in reality though that we don't normally
run into high salt or certainly high
sodium soils in the eastern u.s because
it's a
humid environment with
plenty of precipitation most of the time
but the other interesting thing about
this that came out of marvin's work is
gypsum
reduced
raspberry root rot which is caused by
phytothera species
in new york and a little bit later there
was some additional work in
washington state that
also
showed a benefit of gypsum applications
where um
phytophthora was a problem
so this uh these observations aren't
entirely confined to
raspberries so
gypsum has reduced phytathera diseases
of
avocado and soybean and i didn't put a
reference in there but also on
ginseng
so these are different
fungal species and the
gypsum seems to benefit the plants in
each uh each regard
and the interesting thing about it is
that the affected gypsum doesn't seem to
be on
soil uh water drainage or physical
characteristics
it seems to be a fairly specific effect
of high calcium concentrations
that inhibit the
reproductive growth of the fungi
and also inhibit the growth of the fungi
within the plant tissues
so
marvin's recommendation and i'd agree
with this is that
to incorporate three to six tons of
gypsum prior to planting raspberries on
sites where there was a history of
phytophthora root rot
the
i guess
additional question would be how about
sites without a
history if i talk through a root rot
and then also
what about a red steel
of strawberries which is also a
phytophthora problem and i couldn't find
any
literature on that but certainly there's
a potential for
affecting
any
phytophthora species by
enhancing free calcium concentrations in
in soils
would you advance that kathy
so the other
question related to that would be
would you get that response irregardless
of how much calcium is naturally in the
soil so in in michigan we think about
a balance of potassium magnesium and
calcium in soils and
that's expressed as a
percentage of the total bases that are
on the exchange complex and i i think
you've went through this in a previous
uh
webinar to to some degree but
it
uh i guess the question this raises is
if if you're working in a soil that's uh
already
abundantly uh supplied with calcium is
more calcium in the form of gypsum going
to
provide some benefit as far as
phytothera control and i don't don't
think that's known at this point but
certainly an interesting
effect of a specific ion calcium on
fungal growth and
disease suppression
could you advance that again kathy
thanks
salt stress so i wanted to go into this
in a little bit more detail when we
talk about
nutrient additions to established uh
plants
but a little bit of background here so
high soil salt levels tend to be
problems in arid regions
so they're much less of an issue for us
in the eastern u.s because uh
precipitation tends to leech uh soil
salts out of the topsoil horizons
but of course growers can
create these problems they can create
them by applying
excessive fertilizers
or inappropriate types of fertilizers at
the wrong time
or by using a high salt irrigation water
source
so the importance of this is that
these berry crops we're concerned about
are among the least tolerant of
elevated salt levels
so it's certainly something to be
concerned about and these are just some
rankings of different fruit crops
and their tolerance to
soil
electrical conductivity which is the way
that soil salt levels are are measured
and you can see that they're a number of
the tree fruit crops are quite a bit
more
tolerant than our
blackberries or
raspberries or strawberries
um
blueberries weren't listed here but um
my thought is that they they would be
right down there with raspberries or
strawberries and perhaps even a little
bit more sensitive to total salts
so it's certainly something we should be
concerned about
and
the effect of
fertilizers
on
salt content of the soil
has been pretty well documented so
it's expressed as a salt index
and
here are some of the standard
nitrogen sources
fertilizer sources
and then also the assault index for
those
and we'll talk a little bit more about
this in
the webinar after the holidays but
the point i wanted to make is we quite
often there are published
values for salt indices
for different types of
fertilizers but these are
essentially per
unit of fertilizer not per unit of
nutrient
so
although ammonium nitrate has a salt
index 105
very high
it contains a higher concentration of
nitrogen
than some other nutrient sources
so if you extrapolate that salt index on
a per unit of fertilizer basis
per pound of nitrogen
what you find is that the
potential for salt injury
might be less using that than it would
be if you're using calcium nitrate
and the assumption being that if if you
desired to apply
a certain amount of nitrogen
that you would contribute less salt
for that amount of nitrogen
using the ammonium nitrate than you
would with
calcium nitrate
even though they often are calcium
nitrate is often
touted as being a more safe
fertilizer from a salt standpoint
so i hope that's uh that's clear
would you advance me oh there we go
and there are salt indices for um
phosphorus and potassium fertilizers too
and those are here and
for the most part uh phosphorus
fertilizers are relatively low in salt
indices except for the ammoniated
phosphates
potassium sources chloride is is more
has a higher
risk of salt injury
could you advance that again kathy
and
so a little bit about organic nitrogen
sources a lot of different uh
materials uh here
and i wanted to
point out just
some of the higher nitrogen
content content organic sources would be
dried blood and fish meal and nitrate a
soda
make sure you you check
with
certifiers
to see which types of these are
allowable
uh phosphorus uh bone meal uh fish meal
or are good sources and then uh kelp and
and wood ash would be good sources of
potash
a little bit about pre-plant manure and
compost
additions
and when those would be uh
beneficial
and i think this has a lot of
significance uh now with uh
increasing prices of uh
conventional fertilizers so
you know
these are
national um
prices per pound of nitrogen they're
probably different for uh with
dealers in your area but on a national
average
prices for these nitrogen fertilizers
has doubled in the last
decade
i would guess that they're not going to
go down from that
uh and these are um similar uh prices
nationally for a couple of sources of
phosphate
they've more than doubled in the last
decade and
and then prices for potassium chloride
which is all also more than
more than doubled so it it
is
useful to think about this because it
kind of changes
the
pricing structure of
these materials relatives to
what you get in compost and and manure
sources
so whether it's a
manure or a compost
if you calculate um
cost per unit of
nutrient
somebody's getting very close to a cost
of
conventional nutrient sources
so of course
organic matter has a number of benefits
and it's going to be most
beneficial on sandy soils or those that
had been heavily farmed for for a number
of years where
organic additions were not put back into
the
soil
all of these materials should be
analyzed first
before applying them
so that you avoid problems with
excessive total salts excessive
phosphorous
nitrogen tie up or excessive
availability of nitrogen
and then some
elemental toxicities
you can apply and incorporate raw manure
that's probably best in the fall before
spring planting
avoid using any manure or compost which
has relatively high salt levels so again
that's measured as
electrical conductivity and
generally if level is above 10 decisions
per meter
that indicates a potential problem
you could apply materials with moderate
salt levels in the fall so again if
they're applied in the fall
much of the salt
exposure would be leached out of the
root zone by the spring when you're
planting
so you'd reduce the potential
and of course manure types
vary enormously in nutrient
content
and these values are given in pounds per
ton of
manure
um
issue that limits manure use in most
states is the phosphorus content
so in michigan our manure games are
generally accepted
ag management practices
indicate that
first you should know soil and manure p
levels and then
if
soil tests indicate that there's a p
that p is needed
then apply enough manure to supply 100
to 200 pounds of p205 to the acre so of
course you need to know the content of
the material to know how much to apply
and then if the uh
in this case it's a braid p1 extraction
uh soil test indicates levels for 75 to
150 parts per million then under our
setting we'd
say that you can only apply enough
manure to replace crop removal which is
pretty minimal with these berry crops
and then of course if soil tests is
above 150 then do not apply
any manure
so
whether or not you can apply manure
is
dictated by the phosphorus content of
that manure but also the salt content
and the potential for doing harm to the
uh
to the berries
and i found these data which were
the range in
parameters of 20
compost samples from massachusetts farm
farms and it was back in
1996 but the things i wanted you to look
at here were first the range in soluble
salt content so
we felt
above 10 is problematic and there was
some that was almost twice that
and then secondly the carbon to nitrogen
ratio so that varied a great deal and
that has consequences horticulturally
too
john bierenbaum at michigan state
university has done a similar survey of
commercial
compost
products from from michigan and the top
graph here is uh
carbon to nitrogen ratios and you can
see that they vary
a great deal from
under 10
10 to 1 to up to over 25 to 1.
the
saturated
media
extract is the electrical conductivity
or the salt content
and again you can see that some of these
are very uh very low and and safe there
are a couple of them that were
somewhat high and and one that was uh
disturbingly high so it's uh the
take-home message is uh be sure you know
the characteristics of these materials
before you use them
and the the
significance of a carbon to nitrogen
ratio is
primarily on nitrogen availability so
here's a list of
organic materials that you might
consider putting into a soil before
planting berries
sawdust has a carbon to nitrogen ratio
of 500 to 1. it's hugely deficient in
nitrogen
bark is a little better straw
80 to 1 is still very low in
nitrogen
compost
as you saw varies quite a bit but might
be 25
to one
grass clippings 20 to one
chicken manure down to six six to one
so we think about these uh um
and
on a stability uh
level so um soils and stable composts
are in that 25 to 30 to 1
range
and for the most part materials in that
range
aren't going to either supply nitrogen
available nitrogen or extract available
nitrogen from from the soil
if you apply materials that
are increasingly uh
lower carbon nitrogen ratio so higher
nitrogen levels you are increasing the
available nitrogen
in the soil
and if you apply materials
that are increasingly low in nitrogen
you tend to reduce the available
nitrogen in the soil so these bark and
sawdust tend to
as they decompose the
microbes that do that work are more
competitive than plant roots for
available nitrogen and
it becomes increasingly difficult for
plants to
extract nitrogen from those soils
the picture on the bottom is a blueberry
planting in michigan
there are several of the
progressive growers in michigan are
using wood chips
incorporating those in the row before
they plant
blueberries
they recognize that they need to
increase nitrogen rates if they do that
to accommodate
those the breakdown of those chips but
the interesting thing and the reason i
want to mention that is that
they seem to get growth responses even
on soils that are pretty high in organic
matter
so i think it's
probably related to the fact that this
is a large particulate matter that
they're adding to a soil
and often soils that are high in total
organic matter but it may be
small
small particles or organic matter
where the aeration that these chips
provide seems to really benefit the
blueberries
uh kathy is asking what would the
desired carbon to nitrogen ratio be for
blueberry for berry crops
um
you know and i think
um
what i would consider is that you you
need once a plants are in the ground um
you
would end up with a carbon nitrogen
ratio of 20 to 25 i would guess so that
you have a
modest
availability of nitrogen
during the course of the
growing season
i think that
if you're applying
these high
carbon materials you just need to be
aware of the fact that you'll need to
increase nitrogen
supplies
accordingly so i'm not sure there's a
ideal or a desired carbon nitrogen ratio
and then i wanted to uh talk um just for
a minute about uh learning from one of
my mistakes many mistakes is a couple of
years ago we established uh organic
raspberry trail under high tunnels
and we're concerned that you put these
raspberries in the ground in
in may
and they're fall fruiters so they're
going to have a
nitrogen demand
for the next five months
so
how do you
supply nitrogen to those plants
when rain is excluded it's an organic
trial so
there are fewer
materials that you can inject through
the irrigation system
how do you put something in place in in
may
prior to planting that's going to
sustain the plants through the growing
season so
we ended up incorporating
up to 10 tons of fortified dairy compost
in the rows before we planted so it was
fortified with feather meal so it was
somewhat higher in
nitrogen content
and this was about june or july after
may planting
and that's salt stress on on the plants
due to the incorporated uh compost so we
did everything that you're not supposed
to do and we we analyzed the compost
after we we put it down and we found
that it
ended up being very very high
concerningly high in
electrical conductivity or total salts
and then
carbon to nitrogen ratio of almost eight
to one so very very high in nitrogen
very high in salts and we had a lot of
difficulty with plant
plant death and poor growth
because of that i think it would have
been less of a problem if it weren't
under high tunnels where we're excluding
precipitation that would have leached
some of this material out of the root
zone
but
in any case that was our our lesson
so in summary um
i think uh important points are to
understand how the soil texture and the
ph nutrient content drainage varies
across the site before you consider
getting ready to plant
understand the properties of all these
amendments and fertilizers before you
make applications
with them so under understand what
salt content nutrient content
and various aspects of these things
before you use them
make sure
that you adjust ph well before you're
planting so
even if you're using a very fine lime
consider that it's going to take a year
for that lime to react significantly in
the in the soil
even if it's incorporated
and that goes as well for sulfur
additions where it's going to take some
time
and of course build soil phosphorus
potassium calcium magnesium levels based
on the recommendations a soil test not
not based on what uh
what your neighbor has been doing for
years that seems to to work needs to be
more scientific than that
so with uh with that that's uh about all
i wanted to cover um we probably have
some time for uh questions if anybody
wants to
uh type something in that i forgot to
cover or didn't cover very clearly
i'd be glad to try to address
address those questions
thank you eric for an excellent
presentation
while we're waiting for people to pose
any questions i'm going to shift to the
exit screen
i want to mention that our speaker for
next the next webinar which is december
2nd is dr marvin pritz he's going to be
talking about foliar testing and
sampling and visual assessment of
nutrient status
and i want you to please note that
webinar number six which was originally
scheduled for twelve nine had to be
moved to twelve sixteen
um we apologize for any inconvenience
with that and the short notice
but uh the webinar will be recorded so
if you're not able to join us on twelve
sixteen you'll be able to listen to the
recorded version
if you haven't completed the
demographics questionnaire or the
educator pretest
please download those and email the
completed forms to me and while eric is
answering
any questions i'm going to open that
poll again
if you didn't vote the first time please
vote again and remember the spear fact
sheets
you can download those those are
agronomy fact sheets which have some
very good uh basic information that
would be applicable also to berry crops
that marvin provided for us from last
week
so here's the poll question 14 that we
missed
from the educator pretest the first
webinar and i'll have that here does
anyone have any questions for eric
while we're waiting
there's a question from glenn
why not ban sulfur or other nutrients
instead of broadcast to reduce the
amount needed
yeah so
with sulfur
the issue there is if if you band
in a four or five foot wide band
soils tend to gravitate back to their
initial or native soil ph
so you would have to watch uh more
carefully how
soil ph changes over time
and it's likely that you'll have to
apply more uh sulfur more quickly
underneath the bushes or within that
band again
so like i say it probably
reduces uh
some
work in monitoring if you can broadcast
but if you're working on a heavier soil
where the rate of sulfur
required is
is cost prohibitive then you may want to
consider banding under the row
and then secondly does soil nutrition
between rows eventually impact plant
supply
through root extension or soil diffusion
i'm not sure i
get that uh entirely but
i
from my experience uh res digging up
raspberries and and blueberries in
particular there are very few roots that
extend
far beyond the canopy of the bush
so
i think you certainly could supply some
nutrition
in row middles but for the most part
there
most of the feeder roots of those
plants tend to be confined underneath
the
well canopy you again eric for
sharing this very informative
presentation with us
we'll be looking forward to your next
one
dan welch will be the webinar host for
the next two webinars and we'll be
looking at
managing nutrients in established
plantings
if there aren't any further questions
we'll close the webinar for today
thank you for joining us
you